muchas gracias valentina es la
limitación vemos señor rolando
representa esa lucha pacífica en
nicaragua y la resistencia que existe
desde 2018 hasta la fecha en contra del
gobierno de nicaragua esa resistencia
que él ha tenido desde hace 15 días en
la diócesis de matagalpa junto a otras
personas quienes lo han acompañado y que
el día de hoy bajo un violento operativo
de la policía nacional ingresaron y
pudieron llevarse hacia la capital
managua
a quienes le acompañaban dejándolo solo
en la curia episcopal de matagalpa como
lo ha mencionado hace como siete minutos
la policía nacional en su reciente
comunicado
ya que se debe que el gobierno se
enfrente a la iglesia en nicaragua
sabemos que este es sólo otro episodio
porque ya antes han cerrado emisoras y
ongs católicas
si esta persecución es generalizada
contra toda voz que se opone en
nicaragua no solamente lo hemos visto
con la iglesia católica recientemente
fue apresado un padre un pastor
evangélico por haber profetizado que la
dictadura de daniel ortega iba a caer en
cualquier momento este padre por por
haber hecho esa profecía en su iglesia
fue detenido junto a otras personas en
nicaragua no se conoce actualmente la
situación pero monseñor rolando ha sido
una de las voces de las pocas voces de
la iglesia en nicaragua que ha seguido
levantándose a pesar de que se encuentra
en nicaragua porque así lo ha venido
haciendo monseñor
un señor del arzobispo de managua quien
lo ha venido haciendo desde el exilio
que fue obligado a hacer el exilio pero
este
monseñor rolando lo ha hecho desde
adentro de nicaragua ya usted lo decía
monseñor rolando pues que acaba el
obispo rolando que acaba de ser
capturado no se sabe en este momento
cuál es su estado no se sabe mayor
mayores detalles de lo que está pasando
quien vela por su seguridad quien
garantiza que esté a salvo
si en estos momentos la policía nacional
me sacó un comunicado donde dice que
está siendo acompañado por
representaciones de la diócesis de
nicaragua pero esto es un comunicado
bajo una
ópera bajo un operativo ilegal en
nicaragua
es ilegal debido a que estos
allanamientos se hacen de seis de la
mañana a seis de la tarde